in a street in istap Palapa one of
Mexico's largest and poorest
neighborhoods there's a sonido party
going
[Music]
on sonid is a workingclass art form in
Mexico a scene and one which Mexico City
is just officially named as part of the
capital's cultural
[Music]
[Applause]
heritage here's how it works Sonos spin
deep cut of Kumbia music from South
America often slowed down or distorted
and often through huge
speakers and the special source that
makes it unique they
[Music]
talk a
lot reading out greetings that people
slip through the DJ cage via phones or
handwritten notes for their friends and
families Ramon Ro better known here as
La changa is known as the king of kings
in the sonad world I asked him what
defines the
movement it's part of the poor
neighborhoods in Mexico City part of our
poverty people that come from below and
have grown with a lot of effort L changa
was born to be what he is a sonad two
behind his huge speakers the only place
we could sort of hear each other he said
that he was proud about the designation
of sonido as cultural heritage it's a
great achievement after the 55 years
I've been doing this he says still son's
a relatively new art form says Jesus
Cruz Vias who wrote a book about
it the idea of the sonidero came about
because people didn't have the money to
go to a dance hall or to hire a band so
instead for any celebration you could
just hire these DJs to play in the patio
or the
street since then many sonad parties
have been demonized as places of drugs
and violence closed down by the
authorities but now the same authorities
are recognizing their positive
aspects this is the magic of a sonad
event you don't need an invitation you
don't need to know people what to dress
up you just need to come and the music
and the spectacle are here for you we
even got our own shout out from the
legendary Ramon
Ro still playing his craft in his mid
70s as his art form seems set for
greater acceptance John Holman Al jazer
is to
palaa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer